a
este billete es de 100.000 libras
libanesas antes con esta cantidad se
podía hacer la compra de la semana pero
ahora es necesario un millón de libras
libanesas que es el sueldo que ganan
muchos libaneses al mes desde mediados
de 2019 la libra libanesa ha caído en
picado llegando a perder el 90 por
ciento de su valor frente al dólar y
este martes llegó a cotizarse 15.000
libras libanesas por un dólar lo que ha
provocado protestas cortes de carretera
huelgas de transportistas y farmacias y
el cierre de muchos supermercados la
situación es tan crítica que el primer
ministro en funciones hasan diab ha
reconocido que su sueldo son 1000
dólares al mes y muchos profesores
universitarios no ganan más de 150
dólares para rescatar a líbano la
comunidad internacional exige la
formación de un gobierno pero ni el
primer ministro saad hariri ni el
presidente michel aún se han puesto de
acuerdo para elegir el nuevo gobierno
[Música]
han pasado 10 años exactos desde el
inicio de la guerra civil siria y
durante este tiempo la libra siria se ha
devaluado enormemente en 2011 cuando
empezó el conflicto de 47 libras sirias
equivalían exactamente a un dólar
estadounidense ahora mismo se cifras de
4700 libras sirias por dólar
estadounidense esta devaluación enorme
de la liga más de un 300 por ciento ha
causado que la compra en la cesta de la
compra sea casi imposible de conseguir
por los sitios que tienen que gastarse
más de lo que ganan en un mes en comida
por ejemplo para ir a comprar cualquier
producto básico como pan leche o
gasolina los sirios tienen que ir con
carros cargados de billetes que ya no
valen absolutamente nada los motivos por
esta devaluación son muchos y muy
distintos entre ellos sobre todo la
corrupción rampante en las zonas
contadas por el presente sirio bashar
al-assad la guerra y durante estos diez
años de conflicto y además la crisis
bancaria que vive actualmente el líbano
donde están la mayoría de cuentas
bancarias de sirios sin embargo hay
zonas desde el país en el norte sobre
todo controladas por turquía donde la
libra siria no se utiliza ya
precisamente por el motivo de esta
devaluación enorme allí las zonas
contadas por turquía
salario se reciben y se pagan y los
productos también se reciben se pagan en
libras turcas
[Música]
el dinar libio se ha mantenido muy
inestable durante la década de guerra
que ha vivido libia antes de 2011 el
valor del dinar estaba casi a la par que
el valor del dólar pero cuando estalló
la guerra empezó a desvanecerse en
picado al igual que la esperanza de los
libios por intentar construir una venir
democrático para su país pero ahora a
pesar de las injerencias extranjeras los
actores el libios del conflicto han
acordado la creación de un gobierno
unitario de transición y entre las
medidas que ha tomado este gobierno se
encuentra la devaluación del dinar y la
unificación del tipo de cambio ahora un
dólar son 4,48 dinares a el libios y
esto ha hecho que el precio de productos
básicos como es el caso del pan suba
antes una barra de banco estaba 5
centavos de dólar y ahora cuesta unos 8
y por otra parte cabe destacar que en el
último año libia ha perdido más del 90
por ciento de sus ingresos por petróleo
y gas sus principales motores económicos
y aunque se atisba un horizonte de paz
para libia aún hay muchas dificultades
financieras que afrontar dificultades a
las que también cabe sumar el mal estado
de las infraestructuras públicas y la
crisis generada por el commit 19
[Música]